one of the biggest stories of the
weekend is that Donald Trump has
pardoned that horrific and vile racist
former sheriff joe arpaio of arizona and
i told you before the vacation that joe
arpaio was charged with defying court
orders related to his supervision of
what the justice department referred to
as the largest pattern of racial
profiling in US history and that says a
lot because there's been no shortage of
racial profiling in american history and
to catch you up
Arpaio was the sheriff of Maricopa
County Arizona
from 93 to this past January that
includes the cities of Phoenix
Scottsdale Mesa they're all in Maricopa
County and while he was Sheriff Arpaio
was a crew accused of a lot of different
things unrelated police misconduct that
included abuse of power
miss using public money failing to
investigate serious crimes violating
election laws forcing inmates to live
outdoors in insane heat all of your sort
of things that you would expect your
prototypical Trump supporting public
official to do but this pardon that's
been issued by Donald Trump relates to a
racial profiling case against Joe Arpaio
back in 2011 the DOJ found that our piyo
was systematically and unlawfully
racially profiling Latinos for traffic
stops and detention huge shocker right
and a federal court ordered Arpaio to
cut it out to quote Hillary Clinton he
refused and so the sheriff was found
guilty of contempt of court last month
and Donald Trump let him off the hook
US District Judge Susan Bolton told the
court quote not only did Arpaio abdicate
responsibility he announced the world
and to his subordinates that he was
going to continue business as usual no
matter who said otherwise our Payoh
sentencing was going to happen in a
couple of months in October so by
pardoning him now Trump is ensuring that
our piyo will not spend a single day in
jail he was facing up to six months
unclear what he really would have ended
up with but he was facing six months a
White House official said to CNN
Trump even approached Attorney General
Jeff Sessions in spring asking whether
or not they could just drop the charges
against Arpaio and per usual Donald
Trump is doing this in large part
because our pyo's being a longtime vocal
supporter of Trump Arpaio was one of
Trump's earliest backers this is
cronyism he was frequently at Trump's
rallies oftentimes the unhinged opening
act like Trump Arpaio has been a
longtime birther and for me the
controversy here is it's not whether
Trump has the authority to make this
pardon obviously Trump does have the
authority to make this pardon it's the
substance of it remember that after the
Charlottesville neo-nazi debacle during
our vacation Trump came out and said
there were really fine people on both
sides right fine people on the side of
the neo-nazis and now Trump pardoned
someone whose crimes are the illegal
targeting of brown people John McCain
senator from the state of Arizona a
Republican said on Friday the president
has the authority to make this pardon
but doing so at this time undermines his
claim for the respective rule of law as
mr. Arpaio has shown no remorse for his
actions and in fact Donald Trump said in
that tweet that I told you about earlier
in the show that he kept Arizona safe
this is the first pardon of Trump's
presidency another disastrous move
politically and it sort of vindicates
Trump's critics in the wake of the
Charlottesville tragedy if you're trying
to make it seem as though you're not
sympathetic to racism and xenophobia and
you go out and say there are really fine
people on the side of the neo-nazi
protesters and then after that you
pardon someone whose crimes relate to
the targeting of Latinos by virtue of
them being Latino you're not making a
very strong case for not being the
racist xenophobe that you're being
accused of being and this is not even
the only time that courts have ruled
against Joe Arpaio but it was the the
one time I believe where he was facing
prison time this includes Joe Arpaio
miss spending public money that was
supposed to be used for inmate supplies
this includes Arpaio entrapping a
teenager and charging him with attempted
murder in order to help his own election
campaign really really ugly sick stuff
as our president likes to say the list
goes on the man is unhinged he's long
deserved to be reprimanded for his
atrocities and all of a sudden what a
lucky situation he's finally convicted
and Donald Trump is in office to
immediately pardon him let's take a
break we'll be back with plenty more
right after this
today's program is made possible by taga
dabbe the hosting specialists offering a
range of flexible hosting packages
including dedicated VPS and cloud server
options as well as custom server
solutions and uk-based colocation
services for your business or project
taga DAB's web hosting services support
a wide range of customers and businesses
worldwide including bloggers tech
startups financial traders gamers web
developers and more and taga dab has a
really user-friendly interface so you
don't have to worry about being super
tech savvy they can automate almost
everything you need for total ease of
use they are really proud of their team
of expert hosting specialists who are
also their support team 70% of their
business comes from repeat orders and
recommendations with a growing number of
people interested in moving their
businesses and projects to the cloud
taga dab is currently offering our
viewers and listeners a twenty british
pound free credit about twenty four US
dollars to all customers signing up to
give you a chance to try the service
this is a limited availability offer
first-come first-served for viewers and
listeners of the David Pakman show to
take advantage of it
go to signup tag a DAB comm /td PS and
use the offer code TDPS 20 all one word
all lowercase
during account registration